salut à tous vous écoutez le podcast
envergure si vous voulez apprendre à
connaître le plus grand potentiel de
l'histoire du basket français j'ai nommé
Victor one banyama vous êtes au bon
endroit voici notre épisode mensuel de
Victor et les autres on va revenir
ensemble sur son mois de janvier et sur
celui de ses concurrents à la draft NBA
2023 c'est parti le père et mai Hugo ils
prennent la MA Victor ce fils dont le
destin d'effraya des gazettes au menu
d'abord on parle de Victor ensuite on
parle d'un autre pour la draft 2023 et
puis la P3 la partie 3 c'est un invité
qui restera mystère aujourd'hui dans la
première partie on fera un petit bilan
de quasiment mi-saison pour Victor home
benyama on analysera aussi les causes et
conséquences de ce dry janu Harry on
peut dire pour Victor qui reste dominant
un peu moins qu'avant néanmoins coup de
loupe technique on va s'intéresser à sa
patate gauche à sa main gauche sa main
faible donc Victor one banyama que
s'est-il que ne s'est-il pas avec cette
main gauche qu'est-ce que ça change pour
son avenir on essaiera de répondre à ces
questions deuxième partie les autres et
là on évoquera le cas de Cannes cam week
Morelli de Vilanova super athlétique
super scorer potentiel top 5 de la draft
NBA 2023 portrait Express projection
avec donc Julien et Thomas qui
m'accompagne pour ce podcast salut les
gars
et la troisième partie ce sera un invité
mystère je l'ai dit comment vous allez
messieurs vous êtes prêt à parler de
Victor là vous êtes fait du film comme
d'habitude très content d'être là perso
ça a été un plaisir de regarder pas mal
dommage comme depuis le début de l'année
donc très contente d'être là pour parler
de notre représentant l'un de nos
représentants c'est ça
j'ai vu que vous aviez pas mal échangé
pas mal préparé tout ça en vous
échangeant des petites vidéos dans notre
conversation ça s'annonce très très bien
Victor et les autres épisodes du mois de
janvier c'est parti
on y va messieurs on commence par l'actu
qui va faire office de bilan de
mi-saison mais n'empêche que l'actualité
de Victor one banyama c'est un mois de
janvier alors il est toujours le joueur
le plus important de son équipe des
métropolitains 92 Victor Hugo il y a pas
de problème mais seulement 50% à deux
points à peine 30% à 3 points
trois matchs de suite à moins de 20
points
au total sur le mois 4 passes décisives
14 ballons perdus alors voilà les stats
de wembi comme disent les ricains
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que vous avez
remarqué sur ces derniers matchs est-ce
qu'il y a des phases en particulier sur
lesquelles il a été en difficulté ou
bien c'est juste une histoire de de
réussite je commence par toi je
alors moi je pense que il y a pas mal de
trucs qui se passent quoi déjà il a été
impacté physiquement par les défenses je
pense les défenses se sont adaptées et
ont décidé de
rentrer dedans il y avait une interview
de
[Musique]
d'un joueur de la SIG et il expliquait
que voilà le but c'était de l'impact
physiquement pour pour le fatiguer quoi
[Musique]
effectivement sur le foot rentrer plus
il y a eu un problème de maladresse 27%
moi j'ai 27% à 3 points de pirouane
[Musique]
et puis je les sens alors sur certains
matchs on a je sais pas ce que ce que
vous en pensez moi j'ai des senti moins
actif quoi les premiers matchs des
matchs d'avant on a il y a toujours un
truc à voir il est tout le temps en
action et sur certains matchs notamment
à contre Cholet
il a l'air un peu émoussé
le fameux Rocky wall peut-être c'est
possible c'est possible bah ouais c'est
en même temps il a 18 ans il a un rôle
primaire dans une équipe primaire d'un
championnat quand même qui gagne en
niveau chaque année et qui a un
championnat de haut niveau donc c'est
pas donné à tout le monde à son âge
Thomas est-ce que tu as remarqué des
difficultés récemment sur sur certains
points précis pour Victor homeman comme
a dit Julien je le vois plutôt bien sur
surtout ce qu'il a dit on a eu un joueur
qui a été vraiment plus discret sur ce
mois de janvier et j'ai comptabilisé
j'ai fait les petits calculs de mon côté
sur les quatre matchs du mois de janvier
pour 10,3/3 de match les trois à match
les plus difficiles à savoir las veulent
Dijon et fausse avant de reclaquer 31
points de contrôle il y a maintenant
trois ou quatre jours et donc elle est
sur 10 tirs par match sur ces trois
rencontres mais les trois mois de 16
points alors qu'il a 16 tir une moyenne
sur la saison il prend également moins
de lancer francs donc on a eu un joueur
qui était vraiment impacté physiquement
par les défenses qui a du mal à prendre
position au poste on sait que c'est un
joueur qui joue énormément au poste
cette année c'est sûrement par là d'où
vient la grande majorité de ces attaques
donc on a eu un joueur qui a
complètement été sorti du système de
d'attaque des mètres par la défense
advers c'est qu'il a touche simplement
empêché de toucher beaucoup de ballons
et donc empêcher de se correr sur un
gros volume comme il arrivait à faire
depuis le début d'année néanmoins impact
positif parce que trois victoires en
quatre matchs qui étaient pas forcément
des matchs faciles pour les
métropolitains 92 alors il y a des très
beaux joueurs à côté de lui mais la
recette peut-être le plan anti-wayama
n'a pas si bien fonctionné que ça
puisque l'équipe qu'il a le plus laissé
jouer donc Roanne au mois de janvier et
l'équipe qui a clairement dominé ces
métropolitanes donc c'était aussi
intéressant à observer le alors il y
avait pas très loin de Twitter ce qui
change pas mal de choses quand même dans
le système de Vincent Collet mais
c'était c'était assez intéressant ma
question allez assez simple et sans
doute simpliste mais c'est pour vous
faire réagir est-ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour une bannière pour sa draft
pour son futur avec ces derniers matchs
les plus durs et Dijon ou
il a il y a toujours un moment où il se
réveille et il montre l'étendue de son
potentiel
il y a des phases de jeu ou pendant
c'est pas deux trois minutes il va il va
distribuer les contre il va il va mettre
des points décisifs et en fait moi c'est
ça que j'ai trouvé vraiment bien même
dans les matchs
c'était difficile c'est que à partir du
moment où il arrive à se correr ça va
être son équipe il a un vrai impact sur
le jeu et
il arrive tout enfin quand lui score
l'équipe va bien quoi
ce qui est pas le cas de tout le monde
dans son équipe après c'est vous en avez
parlé un petit peu dans l'autre épisode
mais c'est vrai que beaucoup de beaucoup
de blessés beaucoup de il y a un nouveau
joueur il a il y a pas beaucoup de
création
plus pour lui donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il se trouve c'est c'est tout
seul et c'est pas forcément facile
puisque
impacté aussi durement par les énormes
énormes par les babarques qui se trouve
dans la ligue parce qu'il y a quand même
des sacrés athlètes aussi en face
comment et Thomas comment tu as trouvé
qu'il avait réagi dans cet adversité
puis tout donne de manière que ce soit
dans le jeu ou dans le comportement sur
le terrain Julien disait à des moments
il avait moins d'activités toi-même
terre tu as noté qu'il avait pris moins
de tir alors ça peut aussi dire vouloir
dire que voilà il sent qu'il est moins
bien il force pas comment tu as trouvé
sa réaction quand il avait des matchs
plus difficiles qu'avant déjà faut noter
que son action et son activité sur le
terrain reste complètement présente
malgré un moins bien offensif sur ce
spam de quatre matchs au mois de janvier
c'est l'Espagne de quatre matchs dans
l'année ou contre le plus de ballon donc
17 sur 4 matchs de moyenne donc il garde
une activité il garde un impact sur les
matchs prépondérants et c'est ce qui
fait qu'il est toujours pour moi on en
reparlera plus tard vraiment vraiment
solidement attaché au spot numéro 1 de
cette arabe c'est que même s'il a des
coups de moins bien offensifs notamment
sur son jumper ça lui permet quand même
d'impacter les matchs et non j'ai trouvé
qui c'est pas parce qu'il était en
difficulté sur son jumper qu'il allait
forcer n'importe comment on le voit bah
du coup il a pris moins de tir il a
continué à être impactant il a continué
à faire gagner son équipe tout
simplement tu l'as dit trois victoires
de suite entre Lyon et leur banne Dijon
et fosse donc il a continué de faire
gagner son équipe il a bien shootopieur
une claquette toujours présent même à la
40e minute pour faire gagner son équipe
j'ai vraiment bien aimé ce côté là de
son jeu on le sait c'est un joueur qui
reste impacté vraiment vraiment tout le
match et même s'il avait des petits
coups de moins bien offensivement il
était peut-être un peu moins présent
voilà il a encore que que 19 ans il les
a eu dans le mois il me semble donc j'ai
pas dans mes 19 ans et j'ai pas du tout
été inquiété par un quelconque
comportement ou très de caractère dans
ces moments un peu plus compliqué pour
lui
donc toi tu disais il y a pas de ça a
pas fait baisser ça cote chez toi c'est
c'est top 1 c'est vendu c'est signé
exactement dans son propre tiers il est
pour moi tout seul en route c'est de
cette très belle draft Julien pareil
alors tu as peut-être pas vu tous les
candidats du haut de tableau puisque tu
es notre spécialiste ouest c'est tout le
monde ne joue pas dans la West Coast
mais par rapport à des
scoot Anderson c'est clairement son
concurrent le plus sérieux
pour moi il est il est au-dessus
on parlait tout à l'heure il est là la
palette est trop grande quoi
ce qui explique aussi peut-être que
j'avais noté ça moi tu vois mais c'est
vraiment
jugement de très très loin peut-être qui
il s'est reposé un peu sur
[Musique]
sur ce qu'il avait fait en début d'année
après c'est pas trop trop son état
d'esprit
pas l'impression que ce soit son
caractère mais il y a ça peut aussi être
de la fatigue physique et puis le encore
une fois les défenses adverses ont
commencé à s'adapter et à envoyer sur
lui des joueurs avec un profil bien
particulier des joueurs évidemment plus
petit que lui mais plutôt que de mettre
des grands cinq pas trop mobiles on va
mettre des des joueurs denses un peu
long mais près du sol qui vont pouvoir
justement le le rende de l'impact au
niveau de la hanche au niveau du bas du
corps et gêner ses déplacements je n'ai
ces prises de ballons l'empêcher d'aller
prendre le ballon dans les spots qu'il
affectionne Julien t'en parlais tout à
l'heure tu parlais du poste c'est c'est
des postes médian généralement entre
entre le bord de raquette et la ligne à
trois points c'est là qu'il aime bien
bien recevoir la balle c'est là qu'il
faisait beaucoup de en début d'année il
en fait toujours d'ailleurs mais voilà
l'éloigner un peu de ses spots quoi
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez voir dans un
monde idéal qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
le voir montrer qu'il n'a pas encore
montré sur cette première moitié de
saison
j'aimerais surtout le voir avec
avec des joueurs qui puissent le servir
en piquant
et encore ça dépend où il va quoi
après très bonne Twitter c'est un bon
joueur de piano
[Musique]
pour lui-même
après il est un peu seul dans la
création surtout si
on s'en va ça va être encore plus loin
de lui trouver ah bah là on l'a bien vu
contre face à Roanne c'était une cata le
nombre de ballons perdus par cette
équipe de Levallois parce qu'il y avait
pas son son mec qui qui mettait le tempo
quoi il y avait pas Waters et du coup
c'était très très compliqué ils se sont
fait agresser il y avait des grands des
grands steppes des grandes prises à deux
même sur les sur les pick and roll
c'était assez
fou ce qui a donné plus d'espace à
wembleyma peut-être mais du coup ça
aussi engendré pas mal de jeux rapide
Thomas sur la deuxième partie de saison
un truc que tu aimerais bien voir chez
Webi
Julien en fait actuellement son jeu
repose trop sur du Top Shop depuis le
poste quand il est au poste sur son
joueur face à des joueurs comme tu l'as
dit qui sont plus petits que lui
vraiment propose une vraie adversité qui
va pas vraiment réussir à driver au
panier qui va vraiment forcer des tiers
compliquées donc moi vraiment j'aimerais
comme la dit Julien le voir beaucoup
plus d'utiliser sur pick & roll vu qu'on
voit que finalement franchement cette
saison je me faisais la remarque en
regardant les matchs il donne pas tant
que ça Victor Hugo alors qu'on l'a vu
par exemple au même au FIBA au feedback
qu'on achète etc et donc qui est
vraiment énormément donc j'ai hâte
vraiment hâte je faisais le parallèle
aussi pareil en regardant les matchs au
stretch car à l'énorme strange Cantoni
Davis au mois de décembre Anthony Davis
car 35 points par match mais il y a
quasiment pas de poulet qui est
quasiment pas trois points c'est juste
démolit la catatte vers soi après soir
que du dunker tout le temps avec sa
relation avec westbrooke et LeBron James
et on sait que Victor il est instoppable
sur dunk et même en finition on va en
reparler plus tard moi je trouve qu'il
finit vraiment bien proche du panier et
donc j'aimerais vraiment le voir en
agresseur de raquettes par moment c'est
aussi un peu de sa faute je trouve qu'il
y a des espaces qui pourraient qui
pourraient utiliser dans lesquels les
projets sont confiés mais qui refusent
un peu pour à l'époque à trois points
mais j'aimerais vraiment le voir donc
voilà dans un mood beaucoup plus
agressif et constamment constamment
agressé la peinture pour aller dunker
aller chercher encore plus de fautes il
provoque déjà plus de silencer par match
et je pense que avec les bras qu'il a on
est quasiment obligé de le fouetter à
chaque fois donc je pense qu'il peut
encore augmenter le chiffre et tout
simplement finir beaucoup plus dans la
peinture comme je l'ai dit de me faire
assez peu et je pense que et c'est ça
qui rend son profil vraiment hallucinant
et pour moi il est vraiment un car je
pense même si il se développe pas voilà
on voit des fois des comparaisons à la
crédit moi je pense pas que ça va
devenir Kevin Durant et je pense pas
qu'il en ait besoin pour être le Victor
home banyama prime le plus efficace
possible moi je préférais que par moment
on se dit bah il se concentre un peu
plus sur le point de jeu où il est le
plus dominant par sa taille par son côté
athlétique par sa longueur juste aller
de tout ce qui bouge en fait et
il peut mettre 28 20 30 points par match
NBA juste
en finissant dans la peinture donc pour
moi il a pas nécessité de forcer
l'étoffshots comme pas obligé de le
faire un peu cette année j'espère que
son évolution passera aussi par là donc
jouer peut-être plus face au Cercle si
avec ça
on l'a vu sur transition parfois arriver
avec de la vitesse et c'est intéressant
parce qu'il a un très bon under on passe
au focus technique de ce podcast de cet
épisode je vous ai demandé de vous
concentrer sur la main gauche bah ouais
ça sert à quoi la main gauche pour quand
on est droitier qu'on est déjà très très
bon et bien je vous ai demandé de vous
intéresser à sa main gauche à lui
électeur mbayama et c'est de la comparer
avec les autres intérieurs dominants
alors évidemment des tracteurs me
répondront que woman a le profil de
personnes donc les comparaisons sont un
peu inutiles on fait avec ce qu'on a
donc
sa main gauche Julien
qu'est-ce qu'il sait faire avec on va tu
peux me faire un état des lieux général
déjà sur on peut dire dribble pas
s'étire
donc
ce que j'avais en premier ce qui défend
très bien avec sa main gauche ce qui est
pas facile en fait
autant gestion du drop de la défense en
droit que la défense haussière qui
dribble souvent driver avec sa main
gauche aussi assez souvent et il y a
quelques finitions peut-être qu'on en
parlera qui sont vraiment très
impressionnantes avec sa maman des
gestes qui doivent être hyper difficiles
à faire et qui fait avec
une maîtrise
exceptionnelle alors vas-y tu peux
rentrer dans le détail il y a pas de
problème déjà quand tu dis défend très
bien avec sa main gauche c'est quoi
c'est aller chercher le contre où il y a
d'autres choses en fait quand il quand
en position de drop il est toujours
beaucoup sur ma main gauche pour gêner
le porteur de balle ou pour essayer de
lui enlever le ballon c'est un truc qui
fait très bien et que alors tu nous
avions dit d'aller voir des grands
sachez pas
ma débaillaux qui le fait qu'il le fait
beaucoup avec sa main gauche et puis
après il arrive à voilà à choisir sa
main pour soit gêner le soit gêné
l'attaquant soit carrément le contraire
mais ça c'est avoir cette distinction
entre ces deux bras pour choisir avec
quelle langue il va contrer
l'adversaire c'est quand même très très
fort je trouve c'est on se rend pas
compte mais il y a que il y a que
peut-être quatre cinq intérieurs je
parle de NBA aujourd'hui qui sont
capables de contrer des demain de cette
manière là et du coup sur les finitions
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui t'a marqué
toi sur sur cette finition main gauche
ouais je l'ai vu trois fois faire un
geste alors je vais essayer d'expliquer
ça c'est assez
pas facile en fait il reçoit le ballon
dans la raquette justement
il fait un appel de pied et il arrive à
en montant il arrive à tourner sur son
épaule droite tu vois elle ballon dans
sa main gauche avec le bras qui est
tendu donc ça son bras gauche tu vois
une espèce de demi-cercle et il arrive à
avec le toucher à finir l'action et à
rentrer le panier
la main sous le ballon
[Musique]
tout est difficile quoi la réception la
façon de tourner l'épaule et de déposer
le ballon c'est tout tout doit être
difficile à faire il le fait avec une
décontraction une facilité
impressionnant grande sensibilité au
niveau des doigts du coup on peut on
peut supposer effectivement de la
mobilité fine comme on dit tout à fait
exceptionnel
Thomas qu'est-ce que tu as va ajouter
pour pour la main gauche de Victor
d'autres aspects de son jeu qui qui
t'ont paru notables déjà juste pour
confirmation je suis vraiment très
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit sur les
comptes qu'il arrive à faire main gauche
vraiment très important et la première
fois je me rappelle que ça m'avait sauté
à l'esprit en voyant un jour c'est quand
si vous vous rappelez bien au Game 7
entre entre les Warriors et les caves
quand earving met son shoot sur circuit
vient contester main droite alors que
earving shoot de l'autre côté c'est la
première fois je sais plus sur une vidéo
j'avais dû tomber du coup c'est la
première fois je mettais vraiment rendu
compte de l'existence entre guillemets
de ça donc mes premiers pas le suiveur
de basket et du coup bah ouais Victor
manima a vraiment une très très bonne
faculté à gérer à gérer ces deux mains
comme ils le souhaitent pour pouvoir
compter selon l'angle qui est le plus
optimal pour pouvoir vraiment bien
contester son attaquant donc ça c'est
vraiment un gros point positif je trouve
sinon je suis également vraiment encore
sur Spady Julien au niveau des finitions
on voit pas encore énormément comme il
l'a dit pour l'instant c'est quelques
quelques petites fois par car comme on
l'a dit bah il arrive pas encore
énormément à aller au Cercle depuis
poste et vu comme il joue énormément en
pause bah on peut pas encore voir
forcément énormément sa main gauche je
crois sûrement plus l'avoir quand elle
aura un bon passeur de pique-n'roll et
qui pourra vraiment finir sur un rôle
dans diverses solutions
personnellement j'ai envie qui progresse
un petit peu sur cette manière
d'enfoncer son genre de poste donc ça
c'est encore un joueur qui est très
frêle d'être un peu plus souverain dans
son vrai pour pouvoir aller plus
facilement monter au Cercle main droite
comme main gauche sinon au niveau des
passes je n'en a pas parlé il passe
assez peu quasiment rarement main gauche
il passe toujours à deux mains quand la
langue de la main gauche ouverte après
c'est pas vraiment un défaut il y a
beaucoup de billes qui font ça même par
exemple je regarde pas mal alberenching
qui est l'un des meilleurs passeurs NBA
et il passe également très très peu main
gauche alors qu'il a une facilité assez
exceptionnelle de passeur il passe main
gauche quasiment que quand il va y avoir
une situation et que low Man 2 sont du
côté fort va venir aider pour contourner
ce joueur et sinon il y a énormément de
place qui pourrait faire qu'une seule
main et qui qu'il fait à demain
également chez nous donc c'est pas
vraiment gros défaut je trouve il y a
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas cette
faculté à passer maintenant je suis
vraiment bien le faire je trouve c'est
un peu le spécialiste dans la matière
donc Victor Hugo global par rapport aux
autres aux autres monstres de son pote
je trouve pas clairement il est
clairement déjà très solide au niveau de
la main gauche et il y a un corps
beaucoup d'amélioration possible juste
en la mettant plus en valeur notamment
par un prix par définition certes ils
vont pouvoir être répétant bien donc
c'est également un point vraiment
positif je trouve ouais c'est la fameuse
semi raper round passe quoi ou on reçoit
la balle il y a une aide et pas son fait
on fait la petite passe elle est facile
cette passe là effectivement à faire
qu'elle soit théoriquement on peut la
faire des deux mains et théoriquement
quand on est un bon pivot NBA on sait la
faire des deux mains en cette passion il
y a pas de souci effectivement celle
dont tu parlais
Thomas est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
vous avez d'autres choses ou d'autres
comparaisons à faire par rapport à
ce qui ce qui se fait de mieux en NBA à
son poste
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres d'autres
finitions auxquelles on pourrait penser
je pense peut-être
alors parler d'un d'une sorte de
hookshot ou tu sais ouais un tir crochet
mais pourquoi pas un petit pouce shot
aussi est-ce que est-ce que vous l'avez
déjà vu faire ça ça serait pas un
flotteur parce qu'il est déjà tellement
haut que ça flotte pas tant mais mais
voyez ce que je veux dire un shoot par
dessous quoi et non pas sur le côté un
shoot par dessous est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il en est capable et ce qu'il a la
main gauche pour faire ça
personnellement je crois pas en avoir vu
faire en tout cas je l'ai pas noté donc
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il en est déjà
fait je suis passé outre mais je pense
franchement vu la qualité technique
comme tu l'as dit dans les œuvres que tu
parlais par rapport à Julien de mobilité
film qu'il a dans les doigts pour
finances je pense que clairement j'ai
l'impression que son ses capacités sont
sans limites donc je pense qu'il peut
toujours tester de nouvelles choses et
continuer d'améliorer sa palette
offensive comme bon lui c'est en fait
jus tu crois que c'est toi qui est posté
sur la conversation vidéo de lui qui
shootait main gauche à répétition
mais c'était à Nanterre
fou chez lui c'est que ça a l'air d'être
un bosseur de folie qui a envie
d'améliorer toutes les parties de son
jeu c'est ça qui est fun quand on
regarde c'est match c'est que tu as
l'impression qu'il invente un geste
pratiquement à chaque fois le nouveau
truc que tu avais déjà pas forcément vu
sur un terrain
qui te fait ouais donc moi je pense
qu'il est si travail il peut tout faire
quoi après ce qu'ils vont en avoir
besoin
j'en sais rien je sais pas mais quand tu
travailles quelque chose j'ai
l'impression qu'ils peuvent réussir
parce qu'il a vraiment cette qualité
et c'est assez intéressant ce que dit
Thomas sur ce les bons passeurs de cette
taille en tout cas n'ont pas besoin
forcément des deux mains je veux dire si
on est très Yang on est obligé de savoir
faire la passe à une main parce que on a
très peu de latitude par rapport à sa
taille etc la passe à une main gauche
depuis le milieu du terrain jusqu'au
corner droit tu es presque obligé de
savoir l'affaire si tu veux être un
grand passeur
Victor mbayama peut sans doute la faire
à deux mains
[Musique]
parce que justement il peut il peut
faire toutes les pages qu'il veut avec
ses deux mains alors les dribbles très
bien main gauche mais je l'ai pas vu
faire de passe Mango
c'est plus un côté sécurisant de passer
demain aussi c'est peut-être comme tu le
dis pour des joueurs aussi grands dans
cette phase faculté à être au dessus des
défenses c'est peut-être aussi prendre
un risque un peu bête sans trop de sans
trop de récompenses derrière que tu peux
faire quasiment la même passe la même
passe à demain donc ça peut être quelque
chose à creuser mais c'est pas non plus
une nécessité absolue pour des joueurs
comme je pense quand tu le dis
absolument et bien nous en avons fini
avec cette petite palette technique sur
la main gauche de Victor one bagnama on
a parlé beaucoup de lui parlons un peu
des autres dans cette classe de draft
[Applaudissements]
et les autres pour cet épisode c'est
justement
camouïe more alors je vais te demander
Thomas de bien me vouloir me dire qui
est
cette tombe se prospect qui devrait être
choisi assez haut quand même au mois de
juin lors de la draft NBA alors Camut
more pour revenir un peu dans le passé
il est né le 8 juillet 2004 donc c'est
un des joueurs très très jeune de cette
draft avec du DJ Jackson etc des gens
qui sont nés après l'été 2004 donc pas
encore 19 ans au moment de la brave
genre vraiment très très jeune il vient
du Maryland et il a fait son High School
du côté dark Bishop holding il a fait
que trois ans vu qu'il a loupé son année
freshman à cause d'une blessure donc on
est sur un programme régional pas
forcément les plus gros adversités
de Saint-Paul assez régulièrement qui
est un vrai gros problème qui est une
très très bonne année cette année
d'ailleurs mais ça a toujours été un
joueur high scho faut vraiment
performant que ce soit en High School
ally white Biel avec la team mellow il a
toujours été vraiment très solide ça a
été du coup un prospect vraiment bien
classé en sortie d'High School et les
rangs 7e chez un tweet 10e chez rivals
11e chez Tony for seven et 22e qui était
un peu late donc on a un joueur qui a
toujours performé en school comme je
l'ai dit il a été gâté
les McDonald's américain Jordan Dream
Classic et toutes ces petites choses qui
font bien cet été avant la saison avec
Vilanova vu qu'il a Villa Nova avec le
nouveau coach il avait fait la petite
balade des Américains au U18 c'était au
Mexique il a été il a été élu MVP de la
compétition dans une équipe où il y a
pas de Gigi Jackson il y avait Anthony
black set twindle pas mal de joueurs
intéressants donc il est lui invité de
la compétition mais 30 points en finale
j'ai oublié l'adversaire mais mettre en
finale fait quand même très très grosse
compétition
et donc cette année du côté de Vilanova
malheureusement il loupe le début de
saison il se blesse le 13 octobre
précisément au doigt à l'entraînement
donc un peu con et ça le fera loupé
quasiment un mois de compétition vu
qu'il revient à bras le 3 décembre et
depuis ça se passe plutôt plutôt pas mal
il y a des hauts il y a des moments mais
12 points de moyenne mais on est voilà
pour faire un petit peu le profil on est
sur un ailier de 2 mètres 0,1 qui fait
107 108 kg très athlétique très explosif
et qui a pas mal pas mal de styles à
continuer de développer mais c'est un
genre vraiment très intéressant
une sorte de freak
Julien quel est son son sa porte
d'entrée en NBA c'est quoi son ski NBA
pourquoi on va aller le choisir lui et
on verra ensuite à quel niveau il
pourrait être choisi mais déjà pourquoi
c'est quoi son argumentaire quand il
quand il fait son CV pour postuler à la
NBA
alors juste avant de s'avère il
s'appelle Vénus
ok
quand même ça apporte d'entrée c'est que
c'est presque un évier NBA idéal dans la
projection
il est grand pour un évier il est
costaud il est c'est un pétard physique
verticalité énorme une vitesse assez
impressionnante et puis il possède un
shoot qui commence à être très efficace
sur ton câble c'est du foot et il est
capable de driver au cercle pour
l'instant tout droit et de dunks contre
un peu tout le monde
donc ça fait une ça fait un joueur
alléchant
alors c'est pas que ça mais franchement
pour ceux qui nous écoutent qui ont
vraiment jamais vu jouer si vous
regardez une mixtape de camoidmor vous
allez péter un plomb parce que c'est
impressionnant sur plein de niveaux
c'est vraiment très très très
impressionnant c'est un peu un joueur à
mixtape j'aime pas cette expression
parce que c'est plus que ça mais c'est
vraiment un joueur très impressionnant
côté mixtape
Thomas est-ce qu'on peut parler de ces
autres points forts peut-être que que
jus n'a pas évoqué et qui sont moins
évident mais qui pourraient voilà le le
faire choisir très très haut dans cette
draft l'une de ces qualités que je
préfère c'est son déjà son niveau et
même son potentiel en jeu of ball je
trouve qu'il est vraiment
monstrueusement fort sur catch and
finish il va faire des très très bons
cuts pour se rendre disponible dans la
raquette et après quand tu l'as dit
c'est une machine à est là et donc il
monte sur tout ce qui bouge mais qui va
monter très très facilement au dunker
beaucoup de ferrocité moi j'aime
énormément son jeu de café magnifique et
le point que j'aimerais mettre en avant
qu'on va malheureusement très très peu
cette saison et qu'il a il nous achète
assez faible et qu'il manque pas
vraiment
bouger
quel ranking dans sa position Julien
est-ce que tu as vu dans cette draft un
ailier meilleur que camoït mort c'est
très simple comme question
[Musique]
c'est trop fort quoi c'est trop fort il
y a trop de de flash qui pourrait
qui pourrait cliquer en MBA pour moi
c'est le numéro 1
au niveau des alliés et pour pour Tom
juste pour que moi aussi je l'ai je l'ai
numéro 1 des éléments OK et jus du coup
quel développement tu vois pour lui
quels axes à travailler sur ce que tu as
vu
sur les matchs que j'ai vu je pense que
ce qu'il faut qu'il bosse c'est son
dribble j'ai l'impression que c'est ça
qui va lui permettre de passer un cap
notamment tu vois sur le jeu de création
pour les autres il est souvent gêné
plein de cross qui qui sont pas très
aboutis
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
là-dessus et son poula possible le coup
a pas de points que j'ai pas
trouvé très efficace pour l'instant il y
a des flashs intéressants et Tom
ouais je pense que c'est un joueur quand
même un corps très brut il y a
énormément qu'on a énormément sur le
capot mais qui est encore beaucoup de
choses à développer dans son jeu que ce
soit comme tu le dis le Haendel c'est
pour ça également qu'on voyait beaucoup
de ces passes au fibet des Amériques du
18 en transition car il avait l'espace
pour s'exprimer donc son haundle dans
les petits espaces là la constance de
son tiers même de sa défense vraiment
beaucoup de points à améliorer même
encore plus savoir vraiment comment
utiliser son son explosivité pour aller
au cercle à quel moment et comment drive
plus facilement je trouve que c'est
vraiment fascinant pour ça car il a
vraiment
upside assez énorme dans tous les
secteurs du jeu quand tu dis son poulaf
franchement personnellement j'ai dû
regarder déjà beaucoup de matchs entre
live School et Walibi et le 18 cette
saison je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir déjà
vu un pull-up à midi distance de Kamui
Moore donc voilà c'est pas un joueur
très beaucoup de séparation il a encore
un jeu assez stéréotypé donc pour moi il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de potentiel mais
il y a encore un travail un travail très
important pour aller pour aller sur sa
forme finale qui pourrait être vraiment
très très effrayante donc
à quoi il va ressembler quand il saura
ce qui fait quoi
il contrôlera tout son corps en tout cas
il y a ça bouillonne il y a de la
puissance il y a pas mal de choses
Thomas toi qui est en train de bosser
sur ton board ça devrait sortir bientôt
sur envergure.co je sais pas si c'est
déjà la sortie ou pas mais que tu la
combien
personnellement actuellement c'est mon
homme meurtrière trop donc genre après
Victor et après scout ouais c'est pas
mal ça ça veut dire ça veut dire ce que
ça veut dire dans une classe où il y a
quand même pas mal de candidats au spot
entre 3 et 8 on va dire il y a quand
même des
des très sérieux
dans le top 10 c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment beaucoup de monde qui postulent
pour toutes les places
c'est clair
j'ai eu un truc à ajouter sur 8 morts
avant qu'on ferme la boutique
c'est bon c'est bon Thomas
oh pareil regardez ces compilations
regardez ces matches ça en vaut la peine
les deux qu'on voit ils sont vraiment
très très dangereux et peuvent faire
sauter du canapé et toucher le plafond
j'ai envie de dire c'est clair merci
messieurs
à très bientôt c'était vraiment un
plaisir de t'entendre vos 12 voix de
même comme toujours
et puis nous on va passer à la partie 3
avec notre invité pour finir ce Victor
et les autres
[Musique]
et notre invité pour la partie 3 ce sera
en anglais mais il est espagnol scout
international pour Barcelone roumaine
j'essaie de bien le dire hola Ruben
ketal
bonjour
podcast bad Victor rain banyama
first question
Barcelona team de Barcelona club
[Musique]
je repasse
en français pour vous dire au revoir à
tout le monde n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à la chaîne envergure laissez
une note aller voir notre site aussi
envergure.co notre chaîne twitch vous
fait des bisous Ciao